this is my third time as a presenter at
the student Oscars in the last 25 years
and I just want to say I really think
this is a terrific event and for those I
haven't bored enough already the first
time I did this I gave out the animation
one to a young kid named John Lasseter
so I wish you all the same success our
bronze medal winner was made at a school
that had a winning documentary in our
Awards last year as well made at
American University in Washington DC
filmmaker Lauren DeAngelis chronicles
the complications and challenges
inherent and dealing with parrots both
in the wild and as pets please welcome
the director of a place to land Lauren
DeAngelis Lauren making this film has
been without a doubt one of the most
incredible and rewarding experiences of
my life and being here today and meeting
so many talented filmmakers this week
has been another incredible experience
and one that I never expected what
actually happened to me something else I
never expected occurred when I was 10
years old and my mother gave in and
bought my sister and I a pet parrot this
is the same woman who refused to let us
keep a goldfish we wanted a school
carnival but regardless we came home
with the parrot we named it precious and
precious is now 18 years old and without
her in my life I never would have
realized the difficulties that captive
parrots face and I might not be standing
here today so first I'd like to thank my
mother for her lapse in judgment that
day and for always believing in me since
then I'd also like to thank my father
for his support and advice over the
years and for putting up with a parrot
flying around the house sometimes at his
head next I'd like to thank my
professors at American University for
giving me the confidence and the
knowledge to produce a film from start
to finish I'd like to thank the members
of the Academy for hosting us here this
week for seeing my film and believing in
it and giving me this incredible
opportunity I'd like to thank my friends
and family who are here in the audience
today supporting me
and I'd like to thank the other half of
my two-person crew Joe Bohannon as my
talented cinematographer and sound
technician he literally scaled mountains
to get some of the shots i wanted to
flying birds he is not only a dedicated
colleague but a true friend as well and
finally I'd like to thank the hard
working people and rescue groups who
helped parrots every single day parrots
may be able to imitate our words but
they have no real voice to tell us what
they need or how they want us to treat
them so I truly hope that this award
really helps give greater get
recognition to their plate thank you
you